الاقامه في بلد ارتبط تاريخه بالزلازل قد
يمثل خطرا نسبيا للبعض لكن الخطر يزداد
على الفقراء المدن الاقل داخل للفرد تتضرر
اكثر من المدن الاعلى في الدخل اليمان
مثلا تضررت اكثر من غازي عنتاب الاقوى
اقتصاديا رغم ان الاخيره اقرب لموقع
الزلزال من الاولى لكن هناك امر لافت في
المباني المدمره الاكثر تضررا لم تكن
الارخص بالضروره ففي قهرمان مرعش كانت
اكثر البنايات تضررا ضمن الفئه السعريه
المتوسطه نحو 6000 ليره للمتر الواحد هذا
الامر ياتي رغم ان المباني الاغلى سعرا
جودتها اعلى لكن هذا يجعل ايضا ارتفاع
المبنى اعلى الامر قد يتحول لنقمه ان لم
تكن البنايه ملتزمه بالكود الزلزالي تماما
كما كلما ارتفع عدد طوابق المبنى وقوه
ووزن المواد المستخدمه في بنائه سترتفع
اعداد الضحايا ومستوى صعوبه الانقاذ هذا
في تركيا هل الامر مشابه في بقيه العالم
اكثر من دراسه وجدت ان البلدان ذات الدخل
المتوسط تتكبد المزيد من الخسائر البشريه
في الزلازل مقارنه بالدول ذات الدخل
المنخفض مثل سوريا او ذات الدخل العالي
مثل اليابان الاخيره يمكنها بناء جميع
المباني التزاما بالكود الزلزالي رغم انها
مكلفه عن العاديه باكثر من 15% اما الدول
ذات الدخل المنخفض فبنائها غالبا ما يكون
افقيا طوابق اقل ومواد خفيفه سيجعلها بذلك
اكثر عرضه للانهيار نعم ولكنها ايضا تزيد
فرص النجاح مقارنه بسقوط حديد فولاذي فوق
السكان اما الدول ذات متوسط الدخل مثل
تركيا فتتجه للتوسع العمرانيه العمودي في
ظل زياده اعداد السكان والاست وهذا يعني
طوابق اكثر ومواد قويه قوه قد تكون قاتله
في حال عدم الالتزام بالاكواد وهو امر
يصعب ضمنه لاحظنا هذا الامر ياتي بنايه
سوريا مقابل مباني تركيا رغم ان الاخيره
امتلكت اليات انقاذ اكثر تطورا الاسكندرون
تضررت اكثر من حلب رغم ان الاخيره اقرب
لمركز الزلزال من الاولى